[Musique]
en octobre 2020 l'exécutif européen a
présenté une directive relative à des
salaires minimaux adéquat dans l'union
européenne
objectif combattre la pauvreté chacun
des pays européens est face à une montée
des inégalités et à est limité très
violente de la pauvreté et l exclusion
on est en train de s'occuper d'un
salaire minimum alors que le problème
c'est que un poids déjà trouvé un moyen
pour faire baisser le chômage parce que
les chômeurs ils s'en fichent du salaire
minimum ils ont pas de travail non
qu'ils ont pas de salaire bouna un
problème de développement économique il
s'agit pas d'imposer un smic à des pays
tuerait pas les moyens tout simplement
d'y faire face
vous avez quand même pas mal d'étudiants
ont été faites justement sur le smic en
disant que le smic
écarté du marché du travail les gens peu
qualifiés on peut se poser aussi la
question de savoir si réellement c'est
une bonne idée
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligny tout ce qui au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en dans
tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et non surtout au niveau au niveau
football et ça c'est au champion
[Musique]
elle a une g7 finances et un consensus
trouvé autour de la taxation des
multinationales ou moins 15% werlen
salue une bonne nouvelle pour la justice
et la solidarité fiscale
là le royaume uni un accord historique
et facebook se montre fair play et
espère la réussite de cette réforme
fiscale
la campagne présidentielle se poursuite
en iran les sept candidats en lice vont
débattre aujourd'hui sur l'économie une
question cruciale alors que le pays fait
face ou sanctions américaines
le candidat ebrahim raïssi est ultra
favori pour succéder au président
sortant hassan rohani depuis cette
manifestation anti fasciste en mémoire
de clément méric à paris aujourd'hui
le cortège s'est rendu de la place de la
république à caen bêta au lendemain du
verdict contre les deux anciens skins
est jugé en appel pour sa mort une peine
moins lourde qu'en première instance
huit ans et cinq ans de prison
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france ah d'accord
trouvé au g7 finances la taxation des
multinationales et des géants du
numérique verra bien le jour
un impôt mondial à hauteur de 15% il
doit permettre notamment aux états de
renflouer les caisses en cette période
de crise sanitaire est les pays membres
du g7 salue tous or cet accord qualifié
d'historique
écoutez bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie et ses homologues britannique
et allemand après quatre ans de combat
la france a eu gain de cause
il y aura bien une taxation des gens de
digital il y aura bien une taxation
minimale à l'impôt ces sociétés pour
éviter l'évasion et l'optimisation
fiscale qui révolte à juste titre à nos
compatriotes c'est un accord ambitieux
le taux minimal que nous avons fixés
pour l'imposition des sociétés et à 15%
je suis ravi d'annoncer aujourd'hui que
les ministres des finances du g7 sont
parvenus après des années de discussions
un accord historique visant à réformer
le système fiscal mondial pour qu'il
soit adapté à l'ère numérique mondiale
et surtout pour qu'ils soient équitables
afin que les bonnes entreprises paient
les bombes impôts au bon endroit
il s'agit d'un gain énorme pour les
contribuables du monde entier c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour la justice et
la solidarité fiscale est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les paradis fiscaux du
monde entier les sociétés ne pourront
plus échapper à leurs obligations
fiscales
en déplaçant astucieusement leurs
bénéfices vers des pays à faible taux
d'imposition des recettes fiscales
stables sont importantes pour que les
gouvernements puissent fonctionner cela
devient encore plus urgent après la
pandémie de coronavirus et pourra dany
langue économiste et membre à des
économistes atterrés le taux d'impôt
mondiale sur les sociétés a déjà bien
diminué au cours des 40 dernières années
pour début des années 80
les taux moyens de taxation et qu'il y
autour de 50 % les taux moyen d'impôts
sur les sociétés alors on peut estimer
que c'est que c'est beaucoup mais c'est
juste pour rappeler quarante ans plus
tard d'où on vient
donc on est aujourd'hui avec des taux
d'imposition extrêmement faible avec une
concurrence fiscale dont 15% c'est
finalement c'est pas monstrueux par
rapport à ce qu'avait proposé le job
hayden aux états unis qui est lé 21 % de
taux minimal et puis par ailleurs le dia
le sera dans les détails maintenant il
faut voir dans l'accord ce qui est prévu
en particulier en matière de
progressivité de l'impôt en iran la
crainte d'une abstention record à
l'élection présidentielle alors que se
tient le premier débat télévisé
aujourd'hui prévue le 18 juin prochain
le scrutin pourrait être boycottée par
une partie de la population on le
rappelle est la campagne électorale est
officiellement ouverte depuis une
semaine mais certains iraniens évoque
une élection déjà joué d'avancé à face à
cette atmosphère qui règne dans le pays
le guide exprès le guide suprême
elle s'est exprimée lors d'un discours
télévisé il en veut je cite aux ennemis
de l'iran écoutez il y à un
avertissement dans le testament de
l'imam s'abstenir aux élections pendant
certaines périodes
peut-être un péché un des pires péchés
capitaux c'est l'avis de l'imam côté
chez john connor guilbault jettent vingt
secondes en cabine que certains veulent
baisser les bras et renoncer au devoir
de participer à l'élection
sous des prétextes absurde c'est là vous
remontez des ennemis des ennemis de
l'iran des ennemis de l'islam et des
ennemis de la démocratie religieuse mais
cela devrait donner mardi
or il est mise pour attirer coville
chercheur à l'iris et spécialiste de
l'iran les iraniens devraient largement
boycotté à la présidentielle et
explique pourquoi comme dans n'importe
quel pays
la situation économique est tellement
catastrophique que les gens veulent à
leur gouvernement
donc ça je pense que c'est vraiment la
préoccupation première des iraniens il
ya également une déception politiques
notamment des classes on va dire urbaine
classe moyenne des grandes villes qui en
veulent quand même un roi ni de ne pas
avoir résisté plus aux radicaux il
aligne elle s'est un petit peu rangé
dans le camp des radicaux pour leur avis
et donc ça veut dire qu'elle était une
déception vis-à-vis de dépôt des
politiques modérées en iran sur vd est
ce qu'on appelle les modérés et puis là
la troisième raison mais qui n'est pas
la principale mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
une énorme sélection qu'on n'a jamais vu
en iran du conseil des gardiens qui est
l'institution chargée de désigner les
candidats aux élections et d'insectes
ont quasiment revenue que des candidats
radicaux et 2 ou 3 hrs candidat modéré
mais ils sont tous actuellement inconnue
donc dans cet ensemble d'événements il
ya une désaffection totale des iraniens
qui en gros se disait à quoi bon aller
voter est le nord du burkina faso
victime d'une nouvelle attaque la plus
meurtrière depuis à 2015 une centaine de
civils ont été tués la nuit dernière à
aso lane un bilan provisoire a selon une
source locale l'assaut à d'abord visé le
poste de supplétifs civil de l'armée
puis les maisons des villageois tous
exécutés de sang-froid la taxe n'a pas
encore été revendiqué un deuil national
de 72 heures a été décrétée les
autorités mènent en ce moment des
opérations de ratissage
on en revient à la situation sanitaire
en argentine le pays dépasse la barre
des 80 mille morts un espoir tout de
même la campagne vaccinale va connaître
un coup d'accélérateur l'argentine a
trouvé un accord avec la russie et va
produire sur son sol foot nick v et le
proposer à sa population
on voit cela avec à maillas oublie un
chiffre record a été franchi ce vendredi
en argentine et la pandémie a fait plus
de 80 mille morts dans ce pays qui
souffre d'une deuxième vague sans
précédent depuis le mois de février un
bilan humain qui a presque doublé en
l'espace de cinq mois
conséquence le système hospitalier est
saturé les infrastructures ne peuvent
pas prendre en charge tous les patients
et le personnel soignant vient à manquer
la tel appel au talent immense talent
l'unité de soins intensifs et plein par
exemple un patient meurt et dès qu'il
meure un autre est admis ou un a été
libéré et un autre est déjà admis donc
nous vérifions constamment pour voir
s'il ya une place disponible dans
l'unité de soins intensifs
il y a des moments où il n'ya pas de
places disponibles et cela se reflète
quand il ya beaucoup de cas une
situation que peine à gérer le
gouvernement argentin qui doit également
affronter une crise économique
seul espoir face à cette deuxième vague
meurtrière
la vaccination de la population qui a
démarré tardivement avec astrazeneca et
sinopharm une campagne qui devrait
prochainement s'accélérer premier pays
d'amérique latine à avoir approuvé le
spoutnik du pays l'argentine a annoncé
officiellement ce vendredi le lancement
de la production du vaccin russe sur son
sol aujourd'hui nous avons déjà commencé
les travaux spécifiques pour lancer la
production de spoutnik vu en argentine
dimanche si dieu le veut un avion
quittera moscou avec le principe actif
pour lancer immédiatement la production
en argentine
pour nous il a été très précieux car des
millions d'argentins
vu leur vie protégée grâce au
développement scientifique de la russie
auxquels nous avons toujours fait
confiance
en attendant les mesures de restriction
sont toujours de rigueur ce premier
week-end du mois de juin
à l'heure actuelle 11 millions de
personnes ont été entièrement vacciner
en argentine
et sachez que le brésil autorise
désormais l'importation de doses du
sérum russe tout en limitant leur
utilisation
l agence nationale de vigilance
sanitaire s'était dans un premier temps
opposés à cette homologation
elle accepte également le vaccin indien
kovacs a le rassemblement anti fasciste
à paris cet après midi c'était
l'occasion pour les manifestants en
d'honorer la mémoire de clément méric
huit ans après sa mort un procès en
appel hier des deux anciens skin adjugée
pour le décès du jeune homme qui ont
écopé de 8 et 5 ans de prison fait le
point avec notre reporter et stahl
farges qui a suivi le cortège
ils étaient nombreux un millier selon le
décompte de nos confrères de la fp à
avoir répondu à l'appel de trois
organisations l'action anti fasciste
paris-banlieue le comité pour clément et
puis le syndicat solidaires un
rassemblement en mémoire à clément
amérique ce militant anti fasciste tué
il ya huit ans lors d'une rixe dans le
9e arrondissement de la capitale une
manifestation qui intervient au
lendemain du verdict eux contrôlaient
deux anciens et skins est jugé en appel
à evry ils ont été reconnus coupables de
violences volontaires ayant entraîné la
mort de clément méric sans intention de
la donner pour cela ils sont condamnés à
8 et 5 ans d'emprisonnement des peines
moins lourdes qu'en première instance
est cette manifestation elle avait aussi
a pour objectif de replacer le meurtre
de clément amérique sur le plan
politique c'est en tout cas ce qu ont
communiqué les organisateurs
sachez qu'une autre manifestation anti
fasciste est prévue dans la capitale le
12 juin prochain
et puis un rassemblement également à
toulouse aujourd'hui une centaine de
manifestants se sont réunis à l'appel de
plusieurs collectifs pour s'opposer au
projet d'autoroute entre castres
et toulouse ils dénoncent un projet trop
coûteux peu écologique et seulement
bénéfique pour des entreprises privées
l autoroute serait également très cher
et peu avantageuse pour les usagers
écouter ses réactions
en fait le gain de temps il serait
autour de 10 minutes de dix minutes donc
et le péage est estimée pour 2025 a
autour de 10 euros
donc on est dix minutes 10 euros 500
hectares voilà les grès les chiffres
réels
avec ces chiffres on devrait s'arrêter
là et se dire on pose le dossier sur la
table et on se demande s'il ya pas une
alternative responsable
on est aujourd'hui aux nous alerte sur
sur les enjeux du de l'artificialisation
des sols aujourd'hui et on fait ça et on
a des élus qui sont capables de faire ça
est capable de mentir pour défendre ça
va être la destruction de plus de 400
hectares de terres agricoles la
disparition d'une dizaine de fermes je
crois donc à l'heure où tout le monde
alors tout le monde nous réclame nous
nous dit haut et fort qu'il faut
économiser les terres agricoles
eh bien je pense que ce projet dans ce
niveau là est totalement archaïque et et
non adaptés on revient sur cette
décision de justice du tribunal de
commerce de lille jeudi dernier alcor a
été choisi pour la reprise d'office
dépôt une ancienne spécialisé dans les
produits bureautiques alcan reprendre à
460 salariés sur 1500 un carnage selon
les employés reportage a assigné renault
parquet et bilal moison niche
il fait partie des 50 magasins sur 60
avoir ouvert mais ces salariés sont
sonnés ils ont le sentiment d'avoir été
bradés deux offres de reprise était en
concurrence le tribunal de commerce de
lille a fait le choix selon eux de
l'offre la plus dégradée en termes
d'emploi vous avez une société qui
s'appelle al khor qui est une
coopérative
donc effectivement avec six membres de
la coopérative il décide de prendre donc
50 magasins 460 salariés mais il met 23
millions d'euros sur la table et de
l'autre côté vous avez à des groupes qui
lui effectivement reprend 6 128 salariés
et qui ne met que 17 millions d'euros
sur la table
donc c'est pour ça que les salariés
effectivement souhaité plutôt avec ce
groupe parce que même après au niveau
opérationnel
on sent bien que al corse un peu plus
léger opérationnellement qu'avec ce
groupe qui a quand même une puissance de
feu beaucoup plus conséquente sans
véritable information sur la suite à
donner à leur emploie 70 salariés sont
restés chez eux et 10 magasins sont
restés fermés ce matin
une situation intenable pour les
syndicats qui demandent le concours du
ministère de l'économie on attend en
fait l'intervention du ministère de
l'économie
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'on demande à
être rencontré par bruno le maire
visiblement on doit pas l'intéressé donc
les salariés se sentent méprisés le
gouvernement ne peut pas laisser passer
un tel massacre
accumulant des pertes allant de 20 à 30
millions d'euros par an depuis 2000 17
l'enseigne a été placée en redressement
judiciaire
avec ce rachat par al khor mille
personnes risquent de perdre leur emploi
mais des recours sont déjà à l'étude
le service communication autour d'
emmanuel macron coûterait cher voire
très cher sondage enquêtes d'opinion
tout cela se chiffrerait temps une
vingtaine de millions d'euros
beaucoup trop selon certains allaient
précision c'est avec dell khalifa le
quoi qu'il en coûte cher à emmanuel
macron ce n'est pas nouveau du moins
lorsqu'il est question de chouchouter le
gouvernement en effet dès qu'il faut se
montrer convaincant en vis-à-vis des
français il semblerait que l'exécutif
n'hésitent pas à dépenser sans compter
avec des sondages des études ou encore
des baromètres en tout genre
à la clé nos confrères de l'ops/oms
mener une enquête minutieuse et les
sommes dépensées pour soigner l'image de
l'exécutif et mettre ses actions en
valeur donne le tournis le budget du
service d'information du gouvernement le
sig organes chapeauté par matignon est
en charge de toute enquête d'opinion
pour le gouvernement a doublé pour la
seule année 2000 20 c'est simple 14
millions d'euros était prévu 28 ont été
dépensés crise sanitaire oblige la vie
des français étaient particulièrement
scrutés notamment juste avant et pendant
le premier confinement si bien que selon
les calculs du magazine un sondage a été
commandé toutes les quarante heures
entre début mars et fin mai c'est une
somme hors de proportion c'est à se
demander si les annonces faites chaque
semaine lors des conférences de presse
d'olivier véran n'était pas autant
dictée par les sondages que par des
considérations sanitaires
alors oui aux grands maux les grands
remèdes c'est comme ça que l'elysée a
justifié cette somme à dépenser mais bon
avec de telles sommes on se dit que le
coc vide a bon dos car ces dépenses ne
concerne pas que la crise sanitaire en
cours depuis 2010 cette aide est que
l'exécutif souhaite mettre en marche ses
réformes
on peut constater que les commandes de
sondages et d'études augmente
à titre d'exemple 20 études commandées
en deux mois par matignon pour la
réforme de la sncf en avril 2010 8,7 en
vingt jours pour la réforme des
retraites fin 2019 et vous vous en
doutez tout cela n'est pas gratuit
loin de là c'est d'autant plus onéreux
que les sondages d'opinion ne sont pas
les seuls outils utilisés pour prendre
le pouls des français en effet il faut
aussi compter sur la surveillance des
réseaux sociaux pour tout contrôler
entre guillemets le sig a signé des
contrats faramineux avec des sociétés
dont la vocation est d'analyser ces
échanges numériques publics
busy brain et l'une d'elle depuis 2017
matignon a signé pour environ 3,5
millions d'euros de contrats avec cette
entreprise
voici pourquoi une telle somme lui un
changement de paradigme avec les réseaux
sociaux l'agenda médiatique maintenant
il est aussi dicté par le bas par des
réseaux sociaux par des mouvements
d'opinion qui peuvent intervenir par des
régimes sociaux destin
par des déclarations de personnes qui
sont beaucoup moins institutionnel
surtout je pense que c'est surtout ça
l'enjeu pour emmanuel par éviter ce
phénomène gilet jaune de damas télé voir
une réelle volonté des peuples se
construire petit à petit finalement
patron capacité de sentir que finalement
la cette réforme ne va pas passer
alors esprits et big brother es tu là
c'est un peu le ressenti quand on voit
tout cet argent dépensé pour scruter les
français ou du mois les comprendre selon
les termes officiels connaître l'opinion
c'est une chose nous convaincre en est
une autre et là aussi le gouvernement
met les bouchées doubles
le sig encore lui a conclu en 2018 un
accord de quatre ans avec un grand nom
du secteur la société dentsu haggis
network montant du deal 300 millions
d'euros
la surveillance un coup mais c'est
visiblement nécessaire pour être au plus
proche des français
les termes du contrat englobe conseil en
stratégie média achat d espaces
publicitaires partenariat campagne
d'intérêt général et informations
gouvernementales cette dernière
expression peut faire tiquer et
s'apparenter à la promotion pour les
réformes envisagées par l'exécutif
emmanuel macron et en séries lui le
sondage et d'analysés qui recommande
davantage que ses prédécesseurs
et enfin troisième élément qui tel celui
qui doit nous inquiéter l'interloqué le
plus c est ce que finalement ces
demandes et ses commandes ses contrats
récents de certaines sociétés sont
faites dans l'intérêt général
ou est-ce qu'elles sont offerts aux au
détriment du contribuable pour servir
les intérêts des manuels macro et
finalement vers delà de la communication
c'est un téléphone vous l'aurez compris
la communication à outrance est le fer
de lance de la politique d' emmanuel
macron et de son équipe gouvernementale
sauf que sous ses aspects démocratique
on peut y voir une stratégie bien plus
calculer prendre le pouls des français
pour reprendre l'expression du locataire
de l'elysée en déplacement cette semaine
dans le lot ne se passe pas dans nos
campagnes mais aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux
et si ces déplacements du locked
analysés étaient perçus comme son entrée
en campagne
2022 cette dernière a peut-être eu lieu
bien neuf
le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
s'ouvrira le 8 septembre devant la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris et ce alors
que l'une des victimes est sous le coup
d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire français son titre de séjour
n'a pas été renouvelé et notre reporter
katia technique l'a rencontré ce jeune
homme est une victime des attentats de
novembre 2015
il travaillait dans l'un des
établissements visés par les terroristes
cet homme d'origine algérienne souhaite
rester anonyme nous l'appellerons
anthony il y à peu il a demandé un
renouvellement de son titre de séjour
comme chaque année il se l'est vu
refuser est désormais sous le coup d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français une chute et f
le jeune homme est dévasté je n'arrive
plus à me concentrer je me stresse là
franchement ce n'est ce n'est pas facile
j'arrive pas à comprendre je travaille
depuis
des années quand même en france je suis
arrivé à l'âge de 17 ans donc je
voyageais pas mal d'endroits en france
donc j'aime bien la france j'ai pas mal
d'amis français et moi je me dis que ma
vie est ici en france la vie d'anthony a
basculé le jour des attentats en voyant
les terroristes tirent et il est parti
se cacher avec d'autres dans les
toilettes du bar dans lequel il
travaille est surmonté le traumatisme
fut difficile après ce que j'ai vécu
c'est trop dur j'étais traumatisée
j'arrive plus à sortir le soir pendant
pendant des mois et des mois l'enquêté
suivi par des psys par des médecins
parfois quand j'entends des trucs du
bruit en terrasse à felipe ça me fait
peur je suis resté toujours travaillé
dans le même établissement et ce n'était
pas facile
tous mes anciens collègues ils ont tous
partis sauf moi anthony a fini par être
embauchés en cdi puis s'est marié avec
une française en 2016 il satisfaisait
donc aux critères pour rester en france
mais sa séparation l'a brutalement
privés de justificatifs mais au vu du
dossier
son avocat maître henri braun s'indigne
de cette décision
dans ces circonstances le fait que la
préfecture de police et pu imaginer lui
délivrer une obligation quitter le
territoire à sortir cette obligation
une interdiction de retour sur le
territoire d'une durée de trois ans ce
qui l'empêchent defacto d'assister au
procès des attentats qui doit s'ouvrir
le 8 septembre et qui est prévu pour
durer jusqu'en mars 2022 me paraît
absolument incompréhensible
anthony investi dans une association de
victimes attendaient beaucoup du procès
bah ça fait mal très mal et
j'aimerais bien quand même assister à ce
procès parce que je suis je suis je suis
victime ce soir là c'est j'ai failli
mourir
maître brun va déposer un recours et si
nécessaire a référé le demande
évidemment qu'ils soient régularisés
mais aussi qu'ils soient naturels dans
la foulée parce qu'ils le méritent ce
parce que la france c'est son pays parce
qu'ils aiment ce pays qui l'a adopté et
également je ne voudrais qu'une enquête
administrative soit diligentée afin de
comprendre comment une telle aberration
a pu avoir lieu
eq éventuellement des sanctions soient
prononcées contre les agents qui ont se
sont permis de prendre une décision
aussi inacceptable frédérique calandra
la déléguée interministérielle à l'aide
aux victimes a déclaré qu'une
autorisation exceptionnelle de séjour il
sera délivré pour assister au procès si
d'ici là sa situation n'a pas été
régularisée marlène schiappa ministre
délégué auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur a de son côté souhaité
qu'une solution soit trouvée et que la
demande d'anthony souhaite examiner
c'était il ya quarante ans les autorités
médicales américaines
alertés sur une maladie contagieuse et
dangereuse le sida quatre décennies plus
tard c'est des avancées ont été faites
en matière de recherche médicale elle
s'est encore bien trop insuffisant et le
sida fait encore des ravages dans les
pays les plus défavorisés on voit cela
avec maxime a bola
la lutte contre le sida continue
d'avancer lors de l'année 2020 690 mille
personnes sont mortes des suites du vih
selon l'onu sida
l' agence spécialisée de l'onu une
moyenne annuelle bien plus faible que
celle de 2010 avec une baisse de 43% des
morts dus au sida en dix ans et de 55 %
depuis 2000 au moins 40 pays sont en
voie de réaliser une réduction de 90 %
de la mortalité liée au sida d'ici à
parmi eux neuf pays du continent
africain le plus touché au niveau
mondial mais la lutte est loin d'être
terminée
le sida est l'une des pandémies les plus
meurtrières des temps modernes depuis le
début de l'épidémie 77,5 millions de
personnes ont été infectées par le vih
et plus de 34 millions de personnes sont
mortes du sida
nous devons atteindre tout le monde
partout et ne laisser personne de côté
si la victoire contre le sida est en
bonne voie c'est notamment dû aux
traitements antirétroviraux une thérapie
qui permet de contrôler le virus du vih
est d'empêcher de cause et le sida la
dernière phase de la maladie causée par
des infections opportunistes au cours
des 40 dernières années depuis que le
sida a été officiellement signalé pour
la première fois nous avons fait
d'énormes progrès pour renverser
l'épidémie aujourd'hui 75 % de toutes
les personnes vivant avec le vih sont
désormais sous traitement c'est plus de
27 millions de personnes sous traitement
une proportion d'humains vivent sous
traitement qui a triplé depuis dix ans
mais qui reste en deçà de l'objectif de
30 millions de personnes vivent sous
traitement fixé par l'onu sida
aujourd'hui 27 millions de personnes
vivent avec le vih sous traitement
tandis que 10 millions vivent sans
traitement
concernant les infections les chiffres
sont aussi en baisse elles ont diminué
de 30% en dix ans avec 1.5 million de
personnes nouvellement infectées en 2020
mais ces infections sont inégales en
europe de l'est et en asie centrale
elles ont bondi depuis 2010 et ont
légèrement progressé au moyen-orient et
en amérique latine
al'inverse les etats-unis enregistrent
une baisse significative depuis
l'apparition du vih dans les années 80
selon les autorités sanitaires
américaines
le nombre annuel d'infection sida a
chuté de 73%
depuis le pic de l'année 1984 avec 34800
infections en 2019
mais la lutte mondiale contre le sida a
connu un raté en 2020 l'onu sida
s'attend à une hausse des cas en raison
de la pandémie due cori 19 qui perturbe
l'accès aux services de santé
c'est le cas notamment en france entre
février et avril 2020 le nombre de
sérologies a été divisé par deux les dix
dernières années sont donc globalement
positive d'un point de vue mondial l'onu
sida se veut prudemment optimiste et
garde pour objectif d'éradiquer le sida
d'ici à 2030
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver dans
30 minutes reste avec moi sur arte
france
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite